how do we know if the plot progression
in a screenplay makes sense
well i mean i think that there's it's
just common sense you're gonna
you're gonna sort of like follow the
logic of your story
um is that is that what you mean do we
do how do we maybe i guess the better
question is what if the plot progression
is taking too long
uh maybe that's a better question that's
a good question my question is taking
yeah
sorry no no no that's a good question um
so
so i think that that is subjective right
and it depends on what you're going for
it depends on the story you're telling
the pace that you sort of expect from a
story in that genre
and that style um so there's there's no
you know black and white answer
but um i do think that when you're
reading a script
right one of the one of the big red
flags is boredom
so this might be something that you
can only figure out once you have sort
of figured out your
your entire plot and you get fresh eyes
on it you might think
you know that it moves like a runaway
train and then you might have somebody
else look at it and they say
oh gosh when is it when's it gonna get
going when's it gonna start
right so um i mean i think that
the uh the sort of natural approach is
to get your start get your story moving
as quickly as possible
and make sure that you are escalating
the conflict and escalating the stakes
consistently throughout your story and
um
and building on that throughout all of
act two but if you've done that and
you've broken the story you've plotted
the whole thing out
you think it's great i would still say
get a fresh set of eyes on it so you can
see
if everyone else agrees with you and
they think that you're
the pace is okay of your story as well
right because then there's there's
pacing that's too fast
yeah and that's what we were talking
about with letting moments breathe too
right um because we want to
sort of see the emotional reactions of
stories too we don't
i mean sometimes we do want just an
action movie that just moves from action
to action right
but more often i think we're interested
in
what is the effect of this plot on this
character that's what we actually care
about
when we're watching a movie or reading a
script right
we want to know like what is the
experience like for this person going
through this what are they feeling what
are they
thinking how is this causing them to
change or re-prioritize what
what's in their life um so i think
it yes pace in a script can be too fast
at times um if it doesn't give us those
those moments of reaction and sort of
you know processing
emotions so that we understand what's
the emotional journey
of this story as well not just the plot
great yeah and going back to like
biopics i think sometimes
what they fall short in is the pacing's
too fast because they're trying to cram
too much yeah but and i know we were
just talking about
seabird off camera i i thought the
pacing was great so
but well i didn't have to see it but
yeah biopics are tough because
um i think a lot of times people try to
make
a story of someone's entire life you
know or that maybe that's the instinct
of like this was such an iconic person i
want to tell the whole story of their
entire life
and very few people's lives are actually
one story you know like most of our
lives are episodic
right so you have to pick what is the
episode
from your life that's a transformative
defining experience and then tell that
story don't
don't tell me the whole thing just give
me the that transformative experience
great point yeah and i think that's what
it did for the most part yeah
it didn't it didn't totally follow her
whole her whole journey
you